it was a dangerous night for police
officers in two separate states one
officer was killed and another seriously
injured in Kissimmee Florida near
Orlando late Friday the officers were
checking people in an area of the city
known for drug activity when they were
shot they were unable to fire back three
suspects were arrested a fourth is being
sought is it getting tough it's getting
tough to do the job that we've all sworn
to protect and uphold and-and-and and
maintain livable neighborhoods keep
people safe and and you know these
senseless acts are going on a few hours
later in Jacksonville two police
officers were shot and wounded both
officers are expected to survive the
suspect was killed and two Pennsylvania
State Troopers are recovering after they
were shot it happened at a convenience
store about an hour south of Pittsburgh
police say the suspect was killed at the
scene an intensive manhunt is underway
in Spain following the attacks this week
in Barcelona and at a seaside resort
that killed at least 14 people including
one American more than 100 others were
injured the driver of the van that
plowed into crowds in Barcelona may
still be at large authorities say a more
ambitious attack may have been in the
works Spanish officials are raising the
security level higher and reinforcing
security at tourist hotspots we have two
reports starting with Seth Doane in
Barcelona Seth good morning good morning
you can see how packed with pedestrians
las ramblas can get on a busy day then
being here makes you appreciate how
unbelievable it was that that van went
careening for seven blocks before coming
to a stop
the driver is still on the run Spanish
police say the deadly vehicle attacks
were the work of a large terrorist cell
which had been plotting for a long time
they believe the driver of the van that
rammed pedestrians on las ramblas is
still at large and have not officially
released any specifics on suspects
however leaked photos reveal some of the
baby-faced suspects of terror here in
Spain the youngest Moussa o Kabir just
70
years old Spanish media is reporting 22
year old Eunice Abu Jakub may have been
the van's driver in his likely the main
focus of the manhunt video from a
security camera in a museum on las
ramblas briefly shows the van careening
past the window even slowed down it
gives a sense of the speed the vehicle
was traveling but it was in Alcon are
100 miles from Barcelona where
terrorists had been planning sources
tell CBS News that the terrorists were
planning a larger attack possibly a
vehicle bomb using gas canisters all
being constructed in a house just down
the street the house exploded Wednesday
it was leveled it may have been a sort
of bomb-making Factory and shook
neighbor Nuria heal a block away the
force of the explosion was strong enough
that one of them one of the explosions
knocked out the glass to see yes yes
because that glass and my hearing it
also heard your hearing as heck though
she still cannot believe terrorists were
just down the street the working theory
police say is that deprived of their
bomb-making material terrorists went to
plan B the vehicle attacks which Spanish
police say were rudimentary but they
were also deadly ineffective
police say the explosion at that house
likely prevented the terrorists from
carrying out a far deadlier attack
Anthony